Jumanji the next level
Jumanji 3 or Jumanji 4 if you count
Zathura or Jumanji 2 if you completely
forget about the one with Robin Williams
we saw this a couple days ago at a real
d3d screening which by the way I'm
really happy to be a part of that
community over there Ryan Garcia Serra
edge with 4dx thank you guys so much for
inviting us yes throw such wonderful
events on top of that the 3d is always
consistently great so thank you so much
I always make sure to screen it in the
best 3d projection possible I actually
really enjoyed this movie a lot so John
what's this plot description you wrote I
wrote this myself I take full credit as
the Internet Movie Database the gang is
back but the game has changed has they
returned to rescue one of their own the
players will have to brave parts unknown
from arid deserts to snowy mountains to
escape the world's most dangerous game
and this time around as you saw in the
trailers the rock is embodying Danny
DeVito and Kevin Hart Danny Glover
exactly and Karen Gillan is who she was
before yeah and Jack Black is the black
dude this time so here's how I would
summarize my experience with this in a
nutshell I laughed significantly more
than I did with welcome to the jungle
however I still think welcome to the
jungle is a better made movie this movie
is McClung cape I think there are some
real just tone-deaf moments sometimes
the energy does drag however there was
enough true hysterical laugh that I had
throughout this film that I would have
to say if you like welcoming the general
you'll like this one
you might like it more at home honestly
but I wouldn't say don't watch it and I
don't think it's a bad movie necessarily
like a lot of times it sounds like a
cop-out to say movies fun entertaining
it sounds like you're trying to be nice
to the film it's fun it's entertaining
it's not great and it's not as well made
or there's not as much wonder to it it's
not as much energy as it was the second
one I'm a little lower enthusiasm you
are I think
definitely enjoyed myself and by the
time the movie was done I had a fair
amount of things that I was happy about
but as far as this goes it felt kind of
like a pale imitation of the previous
movie especially because I was really
looking forward to seeing the rocking
Kevin Hart do Danny DeVito and Danny
Glover and do something different there
I never really felt like the movie built
on that other than repeating that joke
from the trailer so I I didn't get as
many laughs as I wanted to partly
because I felt like I saw the funny in
the trailer and then a couple of jokes
would sneak up on me but the things that
really brought me in the most were sort
of the newer characters and again when
act 3 everything kind of comes to a head
that was when I was most immersed into
the movie so not without its charms but
I thought they could have done a fair
amount header with this I'm about 50/50
with you on your opinion here looking
back you're welcome to the jungle what I
think made the the cast chemistry really
shine it says you have these teenage
characters and then they go into the
game and they turn into these avatars of
these famous people and and the famous
people do their own thing they get to be
their own three-dimensional characters
they're not trying to be the teenage
performers and I think weirdly the times
it really limited the performances and
at times it made it really funny is the
fact that the rock is doing a Danny
DeVito impersonation and he's not being
a character he's being a caricature of
Danny DeVito
and Kevin Hart same thing I think he's
better than the rock because his
character beat is more rich yeah and he
gets a lot more writing to do and like
there's this the whole joke with the
rock is Danny DeVito there's a thing
called a callback in comedy and there's
another thing we were like you've
repeated this joke an awful lot same
thing with Jack Black I think they were
actually a little bit scared to go all
out because he's a white guy and the
inside he's supposed to be a black guy
and I think there's something about the
performance I felt held back but that's
not to say that there were times we're
like I said it's weird there are times
where they felt limited and there are
times where it just felt flat but there
are times where they are so funny yeah
yeah it definitely still has those Flint
spark moments where the cast chemistry
comes to life and and there are some
unexpected things with how they use the
avatars that are some of the things that
make this movie fresher than the first
that add
fine what they did that was different
we're on 5050 with you on the character
thing is because I really felt like
Kevin Hart and Dwayne Johnson got more
screen time in this film together as
like the duo of Kevin Hart and Dwayne
Johnson because of the fact that they're
embodying like the people in the real
world are people who had a falling out
in our former best friends so there's
this whole like resolution of conflict
which is a riff on the first one yeah
yeah except and everybody really but
like I said the issue that it comes down
to is they're doing impersonations of
famous respected actors yeah and they
didn't need to do that with the teenage
care well yeah it's like there wasn't a
distinction it was just oh now the rock
is gonna be kind of insecure and we're
gonna watch him play that character out
whereas this was like yeah you're these
two specific people and never adapt to
the world beyond
so there's times when Johnson's
hilarious and there's some bits that
will be like it means movies not exactly
a film it's filled with spoilers but
there are bits that if I told you what
the setup of it was it would ruin the
fun of it there's like some physical
gags that happen with the rock that I
did think were hilarious
word the movie I think misses the mark a
lot which I thought welcome to the
jungle definitely got down better was
making you feel like you're in some
weird VR video game of sorts I would
forget that you're in a video game in
this movie it did feel more perfunctory
even the riddles sometimes felt kind of
like yeah we didn't really need this
it's a joke at most it's kind of drag at
times that sense of adventure to it this
is one of those moves you're like don't
think about the rules but when they when
they bring the rules to the attention
roll is the rule of three with their
barcodes showing how much life they have
left that motif did not feel like it hit
as hard as the first like the first
movie was like oh man these lives if
they run out they're gonna die and in
this movie I knew it but I never really
got the tension of it it felt like a
thing that they kept having to be
reminded to throw into the plot again
it's like you know they're gonna be fine
but there still is a big lack of stakes
and I think that has a lot to do with
trying to commit to the bit of
impersonating Danny Glover and Danny
DeVito in the beginning when they're
like clueless and like whoa well look at
my bodies like that's all really funny
but then there are moments where it's
like later in the movie and crazy stuffs
happening where I
they'd be freaking out they'd be pulled
into the danger of the situation they
wouldn't just be like yeah I'm gonna
make some sarcastic quip you know if
they were to remain men I'm gonna make
some sarcastic clip then they're all
gonna die yeah I'm gonna all die in the
game and that's the Troublesome thing
about the way this movie lands and it's
funny cuz I feel like it's all there
they had the idea locked and they could
have used a few more drafts on the
script to make it rich because even
Jumanji itself they don't really build
upon even though they go to the trouble
of being like the game's broken things
are weird and different but they're not
really there's really only one element
that that plotline goes to so like that
was my issue with the rules because they
say the game's broken and that's why
everyone has different avatars but why
is this a completely different game now
yeah they've stepped into the sequel to
this video game which is fine which is
like yeah you want that's not the setup
of the movie that's the setup of the
movie it's the same game they don't
address it I'm like does it know that
they beat the last levels so they're
being thrown into a new level or yeah
what is exactly happening it's
interesting that the game's broken let's
explore yeah let's make that clears I
felt like oh with the game broke and
that means crazy stuff is gonna happen
but it just plays out like an a regular
game it plays out a lot like the first
movie it's the regular gonna be Jumanji
again except in the snow and in a desert
and with the Hound instead of Bobby
Cannavale yeah Rory McCann does a fine
job bringing presents you know and
there's some new players in your
Aquafina I don't remember being in the
trailers but there's a big announcement
about her being in this and she had some
pretty good moments where she really
shines I think Karen Gillan got way more
to do in this film oh yeah she's she's
the straight man in this movie she's
like holding everything down while like
fridge freaks out in the other tour but
she's the only one and truly familiar
terra-tory where's everyone it has a bit
of a bit to do it's really what you want
from this movie if you think you just
wanted to sit back and have fun with it
and be with your friends again yeah then
I I think it does it did exactly what I
ate just wanted from it I had plenty of
criticisms about the welcome to the
jungle but I still walked out with the
same thing that's fun yeah that's really
all I care about what this is I just
want to walk out being like yeah I had a
lot of laughs in the cast was good it
will never match the imagination
levels of the one with Robin Williams
yeah but at this point both movies I
felt had more potential than what they
lean into with what they can do a
creative set pieces as opposed to you
know right in the middle of venture
where you kind of forget that you have
this thing where you can mess around
with the fact that you're in a video
game and in a day and age when we're
trying still to crack the video game
movie code I feel like these movies
could be a tremendous opportunity for
that it didn't hit quite as many of
those sweet spots and yeah the first
reboot wasn't perfect I just thought it
had more color in life but like I said
by the end of this I like the setup
I like the ultimate payoffs by the third
act for the most part I was thrilled and
invested in having fun so there's
definitely stuff to enjoy it just kind
of came out to be like a three for me
Jumanji the next level who do you think
should join this fantastic cast who do
you want to see the rock and Kevin Hart
impersonate Al Pacino it's a Kevin Hart
Nero and and in the rock impersonate
Danny Glover nan DeVito Jack Black black
guy you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified never got a YouTube video
make sure to hit the like button if you
enjoyed this review as well and I like
to end this with a patron today shot up
to a man named Philip J Smith the junior
you haven't been responding to me or
hitting me up at all I think you got to
take your response time to the net angle
John would the interrupting again shut
him up
oh you know what Phil I'm worried about
you and I'm a little worried that maybe
you've been sucked into your own Jumanji
experience we miss you we need to know
things about you to make these shoutouts
more engaging so uh once you come on out
and just talk to us man don't be like
Spencer in the movie running away from
your friends not facing your problems
cuz we love you and would love to you
know save Jumanji next to you or
something
how'd I do give me a letter Dre 45
seconds I mean that's worth $15